first up the proper way to chop fresh
herbs to get maximum flavor chopping
herb the secret is to chop them not
bruised them now basil this is a soft
herb so treat it with some respect when
people go mad chopping herbs all the
goodness comes out on the board
I want the goodness left inside the
basil place them all inside one another
with the largest leaf at the bottom and
it's almost like rolling a cigar large
one at the bottom small ones in the
center and then look place them down
together just roll them nice and gently
don't bruise them step one
rolled ready to slice sharp knife
imperative fingers tucked in the bottom
part of your knuckle is the guide
between you and the herbs that their
tops you can cut your finger really
important to get counsel with a knife
and just practice rolling the knife
across the board and relaxing that wrist
it's all in the wrist action
so herbs up fingernails tucked
underneath and just up and down up and
down
and there you have a chop basil that's
not bruised and smelling very fragrant
right coriander so you get the bunch of
coriander hold it down and just lightly
shave the leaves off the stalls bunch
them up together and then just again let
the knife do the work
tuck the fingernails in and just chop
once and once only don't hack it just
chop it you can always identify when you
bruise the herb when you've removed the
herbs off the board that's a big green
patch mmm full of flavor and none of the
goodness is left on the chopping board
if you have fruit that's not perfectly
ripe the tip is to put a banana in a
paper bag then add your unripe fruit put
it in a dark place and the banana will
speed up the ripening process of the
other fruit you can't appeal and cut a
mango the easy way
homey you stalk end up cook either side
of the stone cut all the way into the
flesh making squares without cutting
through the skin then turn it inside out
and carefully cut your pieces off a
great tip to prevent burning sensitive
skin when working with chilies to get
rid of that spice and that heat on your
fingers a little bit of lemon squeeze a
little bit of lemon juice and that
instantly gets rid of the heat fresh
lemon juice for perfect ball potatoes
always start them off with cold water
and never boarding water this way by the
time the center's are the potatoes are
cooked the outside won't be falling
apart my tip to get the flesh out of a
Kiwi this is simply cut the fruit in
half and scoop out with a teaspoon try
it it really works
I absolutely love these peppers now they
have the most amazing sweet delicious
flavor with a really nice crunchy
texture and the most exciting thing
about the peppers is that they're just
as delicious raw or cooked to identify
the perfect pepper must be smooth and
firm and not a wrinkle inside now how to
cut the perfect pepper stalk off pepper
down and get the knife start from the
top and slice all the way around
basically we're gonna be slicing around
the seeds look no faffing around but
this isn't perfect Christmas tree of
seeds and have got the mess all over
your board and more importantly is twice
as quick discard that now we're gonna
cut it into a julienne flatten the
pepper skin side down onto the board cuz
it's a lot easier to slice through the
pepper and just lift a knife up and down
and basically julienne is a chef's word
for strips these are absolutely perfect
for sewing and that's what we're looking
for they're crunchy delicious and more
importantly no seeds deed for a great
tip to check if a pineapple is ripe is
to pull a leaf out from the top if it
comes away easily it's ripe and ready
for slicing a great tip for getting meat
or fish to cook faster is to score it
which allows the heat to penetrate
quicker this also allows mayonnaise to
be absorbed more deeply
a great tip for stopping potatoes apples
and avocados from going brown wink cut
simply cover water and add a squeeze of
lemon the acidity stops the flesh from
oxidizing which is what causes the color
to change it's almost like sort of
rewinding giving birth okay
now you're putting it back in once it's
been born